AND GREG GUTFELD.
IT'S 5:00 IN NEW YORK CITY, AND
THIS IS "THE FIVE" ."
PRESIDENT TRUMP ADDRESSING TWO
MAJOR ISSUES TODAY WHILE MEETING
WITH THE PRESIDENT OF
SOUTH KOREA, INCLUDING HIS
SUMMIT WITH NORTH KOREAN LEADER
KIM JONG UN.
WE WILL GET TO HIS COMMENTS ON
THAT IN A MOMENT BUT FIRST THE
PRESIDENT IS COMMENTING FOR THE
FIRST TIME ON CAMERA ABOUT AN
FBI INFORMANT COMMUNICATING WITH
ASSOCIATES OF HIS CAMPAIGN.
>> A LOT OF PEOPLE ARE SAYING
THEY HAD SPIES IN MY CAMPAIGN.
I HOPE THERE WEREN'T, FRANKLY.
BUT SOME MAN GOT PAID BASED ON
WHAT I READ IN THE NEWSPAPERS.
I THINK THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE WANTS TO GET DOWN TO IT
AND I CAN TELL YOU CONGRESS
DOES.
IF THEY HAD SPIES IN MY
CAMPAIGN, DURING MY CAMPAIGN FOR
POLITICAL PURPOSES, THAT WOULD
BE UNPRECEDENTED IN THE HISTORY
OF OUR COUNTRY.
>> Dana: 'S MENTOR
CHUCK SCHUMER SAYING THESE MOVES
TO LEARN MORE ABOUT THE
INFORMANT ATTEMPT TO OBSTRUCT
THE INVESTIGATION.
>> DEMANDS FOR OVERSIGHT ARE
TANTAMOUNT TO INTERFERENCE.
ESPECIALLY WHEN THE FOLKS
DEMANDING THE INFORMATION ARE
THE MOST BIASED, IRRESPONSIBLE
ACTORS, A MAN LIKE DEVIN NUNES,
WHO I HEAR PRIVATELY FOR MY
REPUBLICAN COLLEAGUES THINK HE
IS OFF THE DEEP END.
>> Dana: ALL RIGHT.
I DON'T KNOW.
THERE'S ALL SORTS OF STUFF GOING
ON.
HERE'S A QUESTION, KIMBERLY.
THE PRESIDENT HAS THE POWER IS
THE CHIEF EXECUTIVE OFFICER TO
DECLASSIFY ALL THESE DOCUMENTS.
WITHOUT BE A GOOD IDEA?
>> Kimberly: I'M GLAD THAT WAS
THE FIRST QUESTION.
IT'S FASCINATING AND THERE ARE A
LOT OF PEOPLE CALLING FOR IT,
SAYING LET'S GO COMPLETE
TRANSPARENCY, DECLASSIFY THE
DOCUMENTS, END.
ALL OTHER SO THERE ISN'T THIS
LEAKING THIS AND LEAKING THAT.
BITS AND PIECES OUT.
SHOW THE WHOLE FRAMEWORK AND
EXACTLY WHAT HAPPENED AND WHO
DID WHAT.
MAYBE THAT'S WHAT THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE NEED AT THIS POINT
INSTEAD OF LIKE DRIP FROM THE
FAUCET COMING DOWN.
PUT IT ALL OUT THERE, AND THEN
WE WILL KNOW.
>> Dana: WHAT DO YOU THINK,
BRIAN?
>> Brian: A LEGAL EXPERT WILL
SAY THAT'S A HUGE MISTAKE
BECAUSE THERE MIGHT BE SOMEBODY
INSIDE RUSSIA THAT WE ARE
DEALING WITH RIGHT NOW THAT ARE
HELPING US TODAY.
I WOULD SAY IF YOU ARE DOING A
COUNTERTERROR OPERATION, WHY
DON'T YOU START WITH THE PEOPLE
THAT ARE ACTUALLY TRYING TO
INFILTRATE, THE RUSSIANS.
SHOW SOME GUTS, GO TO RUSSIAN
ESTIMATES GOING ON.
OR USE YOUR CONTACTS TO FIND OUT
WHAT THEY HAVE TO SAY.
INSTEAD YOU'RE GOING UP TO THESE
ANCILLARY PEOPLE ON THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN AND NOBODY SAYS THEY
ARE MAJOR PLAYERS.
TRYING TO FIND OUT WHAT SOMEBODY
MIGHT HAVE WHISPERED TO THEM IN
A DRUNKEN CONVERSATION.
FOR PEOPLE TO SAY, LIKE
CHUCK SCHUMER, IT'S
IRRESPONSIBLE TO ALLOW THESE
PEOPLE TO FIND OUT WHO HAS
INFILTRATED YOUR CAMPAIGN.
IF ANYONE INFILTRATED
CHUCK SCHUMER'S CAMPAIGN, THEY
WOULDN'T SAY THE FBI WAS ALLOWED
TO HAVE THEIR SOURCES.
I DON'T BLAME PRESIDENT TRUMP
FOR BEING OUTRAGED, TO FIND OUT
WHAT WAS GOING ON ARE NOT GOING
ON WITH THIS CAMBRIDGE
PROFESSOR.
I DON'T BLAME HIM FOR FINDING
OUT CARTER PAGE, AND CAPUTO,
WHAT WAS HAPPENING WITH THESE
GUYS.
THE ONLY THING AT STAKE IS HIS
PRESIDENCY AND HOW LONG HE STAYS
PRESIDENCY AND HOW LONG HE STAY
STAYS.
>> Dana: JUAN, LET ME ASK YOU.
THE IDEA THAT IF THE DEEP STATE,
IF WE ARE CALLING IT BACK, WAS
SO DETERMINED TO HURT
PRESIDENT TRUMP, WHAT ABOUT THE
DEMOCRATS FEELING LIKE THEY
ACTUALLY HURT CLINTON MORE
BECAUSE THEY KEPT THE FBI
INVESTIGATION INTO THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN UNDER WRAPS BUT WERE
MORE FORTHCOMING IN THE PRESS
ABOUT QUENTIN.
>> Juan: IT CONTRADICTS THE
WHOLE FLOOR WHAT YOU ARE SEEN
COMING FROM THE PRESIDENT.
THE CAMPAIGN THAT WAS HURT BY
THE FBI WAS THE CLINTON
CAMPAIGN.
THERE WAS NO DAMAGE DONE TO
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S CAMPAIGN.
IN FACT, SOME PEOPLE ARE ARGUING
THAT BECAUSE THEY WERE
CONDUCTING COUNTERINTELLIGENCE
OPERATIONS AS OPPOSED TO A
CRIMINAL INVESTIGATION, THEY
WERE ACTUALLY TRYING TO PROTECT
AND TRY TO ACT AS A BUFFER TO
KEEP THE RUSSIAN INFLUENCE OUT
OF ALL THE CAMPAIGN, INCLUDING
THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN.
I THINK WHAT YOU ARE SEEING NOW
IN RESPONSE TO YOUR QUESTION,
DANA, AN EFFORT BY THE
PRESIDENT.
I THINK IT'S UNPRECEDENTED TO
SORT OF WEAPONIZED INVESTIGATION
INTO THE INVESTIGATION INTO HIM.
>> Dana: ISN'T WEAPONIZING,
GREG, IF IT IS THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT SAYING WE HAVE AN
INSPECTOR GENERAL HOWEVER ONE
SEEMS TO SUPPORT, MICHAEL
HOROWITZ, BECAUSE HE IS A FAIR
GUY.
HE SAYS HE WILL TAKE A LOOK AT
IT.
CAN WE LET IT PLAY OUT?
COULD BE MONTHS.
>> Greg: WHAT IS RUSSIAN FOR
MEXICAN STANDOFF?
THAT'S WHAT WE HAVE RIGHT NOW.
I SEE THE OPPOSITE.
HILLARY'S INVESTIGATION WAS PUT
IN THE PRESS TO HELP HER.
REMEMBER WHAT COMEY SAID, HAVE
TO GET THIS OUT OF THE WAY
BECAUSE IF SHE WINS AND IT COMES
OUT, WE LOOK REALLY BAD.
SO LET'S HELP HER.
TRUMP WAS KEPT UNDER WRAPS
BECAUSE THEY WANTED TO CATCH
THEM.
WHY IS THIS ONE KNOWN.
YOU CAN LOOK AT IT ANYWAY.
>> Dana: OR BECAUSE THEY
THOUGHT HE WASN'T GOING TO WIN.
>> Greg: YOU WILL GO BACK TO
THE LAUREL AND YANNY.
WHICH COLLUSION STORY IS MORE
PERSUASIVE.
THE STORY, IT'S BEEN GOING ON
FOR 18 MONTHS.
ON THE OTHER SIDE, FBI, HOWEVER,
DEMOCRATS, BRITISH BUY.
ONE INFORMANT, MAY BE TWO.
IF YOU COMPARE THESE TWO SIDES,
YOU HAVE ONE WITH A MEETING
ABOUT THE MISSING SKI
ACT YOU HAVE A DOSSIER PAID FOR
BY HILLARY.
YOU HAVE BEEN INFORMANT, MAY BE
TWO, PLACED AS A FAVOR.
YOU HAVE THE PRESS PLAYING IT
DOWN.
YOU HAVE THE DOSSIER CONTENTS
LEAKED.
WE START COMPARING THESE THINGS,
ONE IS MAKING MORE SENSE THAN
THE OTHER.
>> Juan: I THINK YOU WOULD --
I THINK YOU ARE GOING DOWN THE
RABBIT HOLE.
>> Greg: WE HAVE BEEN GOING
DOWN FOR 18 MONTHS.
EXCUSE ME IF I FIND ANOTHER
RABBIT HOLE.
>> Brian: "WASHINGTON POST"
BEGAN TO LEAK OUT INFORMATION TO
MAYBE GET A HEAD TO LET US KNOW
THERE'S A RABBIT HOLE.
I THINK ALAN DERSHOWITZ NAILED
IT WHEN HE SAID I DON'T CARE OF
IT IS THE '98 CLINTON
INVESTIGATION, NOW THE 2016
CLINTON-TRUMP CAMPAIGN.
YOU'LL NEVER GET TO THE BOTTOM
OF IT AS LONG AS IT IS THIS TYPE
OF OPERATION.
WE HAVE TO GO BACK TO THE 9/11
COMMISSION TO GET ANSWERS,
PUBLISH THE RESULTS BECAUSE IT
DID NOT EFFECT THE ELECTION.
YOU JUST FIND OUT WHAT'S WRONG
TO STOP THE NEXT PROBLEM BECAUSE
THIS HORSE IS OUT OF THE BARN
AND NO ONE EVEN SAW THE HORSE.
>> Juan: I THINK THE PROBLEM,
FIRST OF ALL, THIS LATEST EFFORT
TO SOMEHOW SAY I HEREBY DEMAND,
LIKE HE'S NOT PRESIDENT BUT SOME
AUTHORITARIAN RULER.
I HEREBY DEMAND.
WHAT HAPPENED, GREG, IMMEDIATELY
ROD ROSENSTEIN, DEPUTY
ATTORNEY GENERAL SAID OKAY, I'M
GOING TO DO THIS.
THE QUESTION IS HE TRYING TO
APPEASE THE PRESIDENT OR SEE
FOLLOWING ORDERS?
>> Greg: YOU ARE OBSESSING
OVER WORDS.
I HEREBY -- SOUNDS LIKE
KING ARTHUR'S CASTLE.
>> Juan: SURE DOES.
SOUNDS LIKE A KING, NOT THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES.
YOU ARE NORMALIZING THIS KIND OF
ABUSE OF A POWER WHILE THE
PRESIDENT IS UNDER A SPECIAL
INVESTIGATION.
>> Brian: WHAT I THINK
EVERYONE IS MISSING.
TRUMP HIRED THIS FOREIGN POLICY
COUNCIL HE GOT ON THE BACK OF A
CHEERIOS BOX THEY GO OUT AND DO
THEIR THING AND SOMEHOW THEY
AREN'T TARGETED BY THIS
INFORMANT.
>> Dana: THE GOVERNMENT TOLD
THEM THE RUSSIANS ARE GOING TO
TRY TO DO THIS.
THEY KNEW.
THE PEOPLE ON THE CAMPAIGN
COMMODE WE KNOW THEY HAVE THESE
CONTACTS.
MICKEY MOUSE WHATEVER DRUNKEN
THINGS.
THOSE WEREN'T DISCLOSED,
KIMBERLY, SO THEN YOU HAVE THIS
QUESTION.
I AGREE, THE LAUREL AND YANNY
THING.
12 HOUSE REPUBLICANS ARE ASKING
FOR A SECOND SPECIAL COUNSEL.
IF YOU WANT TO MAKE THIS SO MUCH
LONGER AND LEAD THE SHOW EVERY
DAY FOR THE NEXT TEN MONTHS,
THAT'S A GOOD WAY TO DO IT.
>> Greg: YOU ARE SAYING KEEP
GOING WITH THIS OTHER
INVESTIGATION WE WILL KEEP
SAYING --
>> Dana: I AM SAYING RELEASE
ALL THE DOCUMENTS TOMORROW.
>> Greg: YOU SHOULD ALSO SAY
IF THEY THINK THIS IS JUST AS
IMPORTANT, THEN IT'S JUST AS
IMPORTANT.
>> Kimberly: WE CONCUR ON THAT
THEY SHOULD RELEASE THE
DOCUMENTS.
I THINK WE WILL THEN GET ANOTHER
SPECIAL COUNSEL.
LET'S HAVE THE IG REPORT, HAVE
THE DOCUMENTS RELEASED,
CERTAINLY WITHIN THE POWER AND
AUTHORITY OF THE PRESIDENT OF
THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES TO DO SO.
IT'S NOT LIKE HE'S TRYING TO
HIDE SOMETHING.
HE IS THING LET'S PUT IT ALL OUT
THERE AND AS IT RELATES TO ANY
PEOPLE WE HAVE OPERATING THE
THEATER THEY COULD RECOVER MOST,
YOU CAN REDACT THEIR NAMES.